who is it
infinity war [ __ ] infinity war zone
thanks for getting my ticket John
as soon as YouTube fixes the yellow
dollar bill sign which would be any
second now
I've been no you oh hey Greg did I wake
you
couldn't sleep it sucks that you can't
come you sure you can't buy another
ticket
no Madden movie sold out for weeks gonna
be the last one to see infinity war no
word from Andrew yet last time I talked
to him he was picking on my ticket but
now nobody's heard from him for weeks
I'm so sorry
that sucks man
you know man is it it's okay it's okay
it's okay
don't worry about you guys go enjoy the
movie and you guys let me know how it is
okay
no spoilers though
[Laughter]
so in hacker computer
dude Craig I think you should go back to
sleep
[Music]
I know that road
what is this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
great
did you know
I didn't know was him don't [ __ ] me
either man
did you know a tour of my tickets you're
more concerned with the ticket than the
fact that he killed Angie just tell me
Kyle
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right fine you can have my ticket
all right no actual review just a sketch
thanks for watching you guys can
subscribe to the region real quick
before we go into our infinity war
review which we just got back from
seeing literally like a half hour ago
will be completely spoiler free don't
want to give away any surprises I wanted
to say thank you to a few people without
this out with that video first off kyle
i Lerman from the fan theory youtube
channel you could watch this challenge
as a lot of reactions over there as well
he helped us out with a VFX he of course
played Kyle and Captain America outfit
want to say thinking to hand you Gordon
for coming all the way over here to help
us out with that by the way that segment
where he had a tear cuz not a fake tear
through John and I bought for a bit and
of course my lovely lady Olivia for
helping us out with the video she'd
helped us out with the holding the mic
for pretty much every single shot help
that was some camera angles one ah so
Thank You Olivia my dear and the main
song featured in through most of that
video that comes from james cherf has a
song the hidden really appreciate
getting to use that song on to infinity
war the most hyped movie of the year and
it's only April people how do you begin
we're talking about this movie it's like
over two and a half hours it's quite an
epic adventure it is huge it's huge epic
in scope does it houses an epic it
doesn't feel like an epic more so than
just a blockbuster adventure and it is
very immediate as well this movie just
throws you into it the tuition at hand
and whoa [ __ ] we're not prepared we're
just gonna start attacking it you know
the way the Russo brothers have talked
about what they wanted to do with the
film they've pretty much executed all
around is it a perfect movie no it's not
but I like the ticking time-bomb the
situation you can feel this like ticking
clock throughout the whole movie and
they also kept talking about how the
anos is essentially like the main
character of this movie he's the
centerpiece you think an Avengers movie
the villain really Thanos is probably
the biggest takeaway I would have with
this film he is the core of this movie
and a number I'm not only the main
villain but he's also the emotional core
of the movie he is the most sort of
surprising and most intriguing character
cuz the rest of them we already know or
are working for them yeah we know the
personalities of all the Avengers that
are featured in here and it's not like
there's a huge amount of
evolution for a lot of these characters
here now the Avengers are straight on
some we want to watch this a second time
we already have tickets to watch it a
second time then we're gonna go into an
in-depth spoiler review to really talk
about cuz there's plenty of spoilers to
be had you know in this movie there's a
lot of surprises a good amount of things
that are pretty predictable things that
I was kind of surprised by how some
things were a little too predictable
I feel like this movie lives and dies by
its details and the details are what
surprised me a lot more than any plot
turn or twist yeah and there's also some
of the best action sequences that you'll
ever see in any of these MCU yeah hands
down the visual and the production
design elements are top-notch in the
most part my favorite interactions the
most fun and exciting interactions were
between Doctor Strange Spider Man Iron
Man and star-lord specifically like
they're especially Tony playing off
strange yeah was them that was the best
interaction I think yeah the best
dynamic interaction I feel like that
worked where the star-lord 1/2 Wade
there were times where I really liked
Starla there are other times where I was
like yeah I kind of don't really like
the way there's being handled here hey
really back and forth with star-lord
he's got that Chris Pratt curse for me
now or I'm like half the time I'm in and
half the time of it yeah going on with
you dude most people pretty much get
equal focus in this film because there
are times where you're like spending a
lot of times with certain characters
you're like yeah I've seen Tony Stark in
quite a while actually I don't see
spider-man quite a lot like they had to
balance it out so made sense they made
Thanos the centerpiece when you're
dealing with it in Samba this huge I
will say that there were a couple of
characters that I thought were evolved
or may or had the best performance
they've had in any of these Avengers
films specifically vision and
specifically Scarlet Witch this is
easily the coolest Scarlet Witch has
ever been and is the most emotionally
invested in vision we've ever been as
well there's a lot of fight scenes in
this movie this movie is not shy of
fight scenes that's what you would want
in this film and there are some fight
scenes that stand out to me more than
other fight sequences without giving it
away into specifics there's that one
scene in the trailer where you see like
spider-man zipping around there's like
things flying in debris and some type of
red planet that whole sequence was
easily my favorite fight scene in the
whole movie a lot of what happens
yeah some of the best stuff in the movie
that I'm emotional wise yeah is one of
the more effective ensembles in terms of
movie overall and I would also say out
of like the Avengers movies this is
easily the most emotional one it lives
up to that high when I was looking
around there were people who have really
glassy eyes is you know yeah you
definitely feel the stakes you
definitely feel the hopelessness that
begins to arise just as the movie clips
further and viateur along and that is
something distinct that like age of
Ultron did not translate that I think
this one does even though it is so vast
in what it's trying to accomplish in all
the places you're jumping to I feel like
that's the gift and the curse of
infinity war is there are so many things
happening and some of them are really
great and some of them are really
resonant not all of them get the time to
be yeah overall film overall if you're
going in for like the epicness of these
all these characters coming in on screen
it's awesome it's badass
oh yeah Avengers movie is one of the
coolest for just the fact that you have
so many of the characters and and it's
again it's one of those like gift and
curse things for the film itself but
like we know them also you can skip I
guess theoretically a certain amount of
character moments in favor of these
people have to match up against these
people or you know oh we're gonna pair
these two off now and see how they get
along in a very comic book kind of way I
thought this movie succeeded with the
Avengers theme overall but if you want
to have you know really defined Avengers
like take the lead that's not the kind
of movies no this is not the kind of
movie there are surprises to be had in
here there's some or some awesome weapon
upgrades in here the fight scenes are
great Thanos is great the cast all does
an amazingly solid job I really think
the last 30 to 40 minutes of this movie
is exactly what you show up for in terms
of epicness and action scale and
emotional weight this film delivers on
that in the last 40 minutes yeah I think
the Russo brothers have done a good job
of crafting something that is epic that
is really well realized so that any any
complaints you might have about the way
the movie moves or the kind of character
details of the amount of attention it
gives to certain people I think they are
able to kind of supersede the the
detrimental sides of those things by
making it so crafted
and so symmetrical for how much they're
trying to do and if I don't think this
is a perfect movie I do have to commend
and appreciate oh absolutely
all the work and all the guidance they
put into it because it does feel like a
Marvel epic you know on a different
scale definitely with a scary villain
who by the end of it you're like yeah
yeah because the movie has so many
characters some of them are meeting each
other for the first time that's where
some of the issues of the film actually
come in the first half-hour or the 40
minutes of this lengthy film was a lot
of humor and a lot of energy and very
fast-paced I was on intros and stuff
like that that they rely on that sort of
thing and I felt like man this who's
gonna fly by quick I could feel this
link at all but then there's a chunk in
the middle where there's so many
different tonal shifts and that's why I
was saying that I think on a second
viewing it could be a very different
experience just also in the wake of all
this hype you know yeah it's always
different on the second go with a movie
like this when there's tonal shifts
sometimes I would there be some
readjusting I would have to do
personally where I'm logically grasping
everything but there are times where my
heart just wasn't in it there were times
where it would kind of drag and there
were times where there were some pacing
issues for me it's sometimes it moves
way too quick sometimes it kind of drags
with certain characters storylines
certain scenes will pop up and you'll be
like that was what brie yeah brief okay
sometimes it's a little choppy and then
you kind of have to forgive it cuz
you're like well this is that ultimate
today culmination pared it down and for
that it still looks pretty polished yeah
the pace isn't terrible as you can tell
that there was probably more here to
begin with black panther is kind of
underutilized you're certainly focusing
on him a lot when he pops up but doing
less things than when you pop in on this
everybody else like when everybody else
you pop it on it's for something like
enormous is happening yeah and when you
get to a condo you're just like oh yeah
let's hang out with Black Manta for a
while the film is so Claudie
there's moving so fast and most of the
conversations in the movie about how
we're gonna take down yeah yeah that's
like 95% of the conversations is two and
a half hour movie you don't really get
too many character moments so sometimes
this one of the performances other than
having humorous moments or gain their
personís shine can feel rather like the
one note that we know these Avengers
characters to be what's the easiest
emotion to slide in and
I would say is written really well and
Josh Browns performance is done very
well I couldn't help but feel there were
certain scenes that specifically with
Thanos where it's like wow he looks very
real and another times where I'm like he
looks very cartoony and there are a
couple characters like on his squad yeah
like you say out of a videogame yeah
they're especially that big battle in
Wakanda yeah yeah girl especially with
the horns like she was sitting there why
did you see Jesus it was borderline
Steppenwolf territory epidemis
the movie I thought was a cool character
head of everyone in the Black Order I
thought he was the coolest one and he
had the most to do and he had the most
unique skill set so he was easily the
most interesting one had a lot more a
skill set yeah yeah the rest of them are
just fighters who seem like they can be
taken down pretty easily by the other
Avengers you know like it wasn't too
much of a challenge if I were to gray
this based off using anyone elses
grading scale I would probably give this
like a 90 percent of rotten tomatoes or
an eight point five out of ten or a four
out of five stars I'd say maybe even a
four and a half but the thing is I feel
like a second viewing keep in mind we
just walked out of this movie reflecting
on it this does soon at the kind of
movie that while I reflect on it I'm
gonna love it even more right now
there's still like a lot of absorption
go watch it you probably already yeah
you just know that we really did enjoy
the hell out of it it was a really good
time getting like two hours of sleep it
was pretty easy to stay awake yeah yeah
all right guys we keep a look out for
our spoiler talk of the move you're
gonna go watch the second time so we can
really absorb it digest it and then
we'll go into a spoiler review who knows
maybe our opinion might change I feel
like it's probably gonna be a more
positive like even more positive
inducing the second time around you guys
can subscribe to the real rejects join
the reject nation click that
notification bell you get notified when
a video bars is up and you can check us
out on patreon full-length TV show
reactions weekly QAS it's because of the
people at patreon
that has allowed us the time and energy
to put together more sketches this year
than we ever have actually I might even
do a supercut of all the sketches that
have appeared before the reactions and
stuff so thank you guys so much